divers scouring a reef near the island
of utila they're on the hunt for a
venomous invasive species with a
voracious appetite just lionfish are a
little more dangerous because they have
more Caitlin Maurer an instructor at
underwater Vision Dive Center knows all
too well the devastating potential of a
lionfish invasion having Dove here
three years ago to now
The Reef is noticeably different and a
lot of that has to do with the predation
of lionfish on some of the smaller
species we have the Third
though native to the indo-pacific
lionfish were first spotted off the
eastern coast of the U.S in the 1980s
likely introduced to the waters off the
Florida Peninsula by humans since then
invasive populations have spread
exponentially
adopted that's a
found almost anywhere
we visited a dive site just minutes from
utila's East Harbor it wasn't long
before we spotted our first lionfish
capturing one however isn't as easy as
it looks securing a kill takes practice
and skill
there's also the matter of not getting
stung though not considered deadly to
humans The lionfish's Sting is
notoriously painful
we're back from the hunt and this is our
Bounty up close we can really appreciate
all the spines surrounding the lionfish
18 spines in total kind of like a
peacock but packed with Venom
once properly filleted lionfish can be
prepared in various ways in this case
Ceviche a simple recipe involving lemon
juice and spices interesting because
they're eating everything
conservationists like Andrea isagire say
that marketing lionfish as a local
delicacy is the key to sustainable
conservation if the community joins
together and commercializes lionfish as
this tasty treat then more people will
know there will be more efforts being
funded into research on them there will
be more people out there hunting them
experts say that while there's no
turning back the lionfish Invasion
efforts by dive communities like those
in the bay islands of Honduras have
proven very effective so just by
taking Spears on Dives or having more
people that know about lionfish and why
there's so much of an issue and how to
safely and to mainly kind of help to
mitigate it and get rid of them it
actually makes a really huge difference
Al Jazeera utila Honduras